hi I'm Patti Kim today we're setting our
sights on him
a land of deserts and rainforests modern
cities ancient beliefs over billion
India's the world's largest dollars
[Music]
in truth there is no one India and to
visit is to move among a dazzling
diversity of geography peoples languages
and customs in the north a rugged
Himalayan region shares boundaries with
Pakistan China and Nepal
further south mountains give way to
plains and jungles vast deserts in the
West and in the east monsoon laden
forests and prolific tea plantations all
this is surrounded by beautiful beaches
and the waters of the Arabian Sea the
Indian Ocean and the Bay of Bengal
journeys through India often begin a new
delhi the capital city and the
commercial hub of the north british
colonizers adopted this city as their
government seat in 1931 choosing a site
where successive generations had left
temples and mosques dating back to the
11th century when India gained
independence in 1947
it kept New Delhi as the capital and the
city as blossoming India has been called
a land of many faiths and many
travellers come to experience
India's religious life with its
epicenter at varanasi on the banks of
the ganges river for the country's tens
of millions of Hindu devotees of
image to this city and a bath in the
holy river are
lifetime goals and to die here is to
have the greatest chance for salvation
in the Hindu religion many animals are
believed to be a divine manifestation of
the gods the multi degree Ganesh temple
in Jaipur
worshipers pray for protection and the
removal of obstacles from their lives
the other temples honor the rat and the
monkey rituals and festivals continue to
play a hugely important role in
religious life traditions for Hindus and
large groups of Buddhists and Muslims
too that date back thousands of years
over these years a rich and varied
history has been built along with a
succession of wars and empires that have
left their marks and their monuments to
the Taj Mahal in the northern city of
Agra is one of the most famous it was
built in the 17th century by the Mughal
Emperor Shah Jahan as a mausoleum for
late wife who died while giving birth
after ordering his court into a two-year
mourning period
he began construction of this national
treasure often referred to as a poem in
stone for more striking architecture at
south to the palaces of who die poor the
city's beautiful lakes and romantic
charms have earned it the nickname
Venice of the east for those with an eye
for wildlife India's national parks and
nature preserves rank among the best in
the world Tigers roam the jungles
crocodiles lurk in mangroves an
elephant's stop through forests the list
goes on and on the best viewing season
for wildlife is March to June the pre
monsoon period when animals have less
choice of watering holes so if you're
looking for adventure luxurious beaches
or a contrast of cultures old and new
it's all just a matter of which India
you want to see as with any crowded
country give yourself extra time to get
where you're going
on any trip the journey can be just as
interesting as the destination
[Music]